>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Bueno, muy buenas tardes,
y bienvenidos a la XXVI Edición
del Maratón de Poesía del Teatro
de la Luna.
En nombre de Georgette Dorn,
directora de la División
Hispánica de la Biblioteca del
Congreso, es un honor para mí
recibir este grupo de poetas,
aquí en la biblioteca,
especialmente a Rei Berroa
quien será nuestro moderador del
evento de hoy y podrá ofrecerle
más información acerca de esta
tradición literaria de
Washington D.C. que es el
Maratón de Poesía,
Poetry Marathon.
No quiero dejarlos sin antes
invitarlos a pasar por la
División Hispánica que está
localizada en la Sala 240 del
Edificio Jefferson.
La división es el portal a
nuestra colección de más de 12
millones de ítems en la
biblioteca que tienen que ver
con todos nuestros países y
otros países de América Latina,
con España, Portugal y
latinos en Estados Unidos.
Los invito además a que escuchen
grabaciones de autores leyendo
sus propias obras en el
archivo de la palabra,
que desde 1943 ha capturado más
de 750 autores, leyendo su obra.
Entonces es una joya que se
trabaja aquí en la división.
Los dejo sin más,
con Rei Berroa,
que va a moderar el evento y
nuestros mejores deseos para un
maratón exitoso.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Buenas
tardes, buenas tardes.
Llevamos 26 años haciendo esta
fiesta y yo me imagino que
ustedes se estarán
preguntando, "pero 26 años,
eso no es nada",
como diría Gardel.
Claro, porque él se murió a los
40, [risas], entonces claro,
no tiene la opción
de tener la variedad.
De estos 26 años, llevamos
17 viniendo a la Biblioteca
del Congreso.
No está presente Georgette Dorn,
ahora que se nos jubila
la semana que viene.
Desafortunadamente, yo tengo
que ser jurado en una tesis de
doctorado, en la República
Dominicana la semana que viene y
no voy a estar presente en esto,
pero mis amadas compañeras de
la biblioteca van a estar en la
compañía de Georgette, y yo me
imagino que yo estaré presente
de otra manera, como
hablábamos hace un rato,
en la fiesta de los muertos de
México que se prepara el altar,
se pone la comida que esa
persona amaba y todos celebran
no sólo la memoria, sino
la presencia de ese ser.
Yo voy a estar presente en
la celebración de la partida
de Georgette.
Que ha estado siempre, ha sido
siempre muy entusiasta con este
evento, con este encuentro para
el cual es una de las cosas que
yo siempre le digo
a todo el mundo,
el Maratón de Poesía se hace
en el Teatro de la Luna y en la
Biblioteca del Congreso.
Y evidentemente, el Teatro de la
Luna es un referente porque ya
llevamos desde 1991, cuando
comenzamos con el teatro,
pero el hecho de poder
traer a los poetas acá,
es un motivo muy especial para
nosotros que yo espero que
podamos seguir haciendo
mientras tengamos aliento.
Porque los seres se dividen en
animados y desanimados, [risas].
Y estos que estamos aquí no
tenemos ningún deseo de andar o
entrar en el desánimo.
Así que -- y esto
va pa' largo, ¿eh?
Porque como decía nuestro
amigo Nicanor Parra,
"no me voy a morir mientras
no me den el Premio Nobel",
[risas].
Nosotros no tenemos esa
pretensión, pero sí decimos,
mientras tengamos algo que
decir, vamos a venir a decirlo.
Y esta es la promesa que yo me
hago todos los años cuando al
terminar el maratón
quedas explotado,
y dices "pero ¿por qué
yo estoy haciendo eso?",
y después recuerdas
cada una de las caras,
y recuerdas los poemas y
recuerdas las experiencias,
y dices, "esto no
tiene ningún precio".
El precio es la experiencia de
la poesía y la experiencia de la
poesía, como dicen los poetas
es la de un viaje constante.
En la vida lo más
importante es viajar,
y el viaje es el viaje al cual
nos traen cada uno de estos
hombres y mujeres.
Desafortunadamente este año
solamente tenemos una mujer,
las otras compañeras que fueron
invitadas no pudieron venir o en
último momento se echaron,
pero como ustedes saben,
Yanet es testigo de esto,
mi interés es que siempre
haya un equilibrio,
porque si somos hombres y
mujeres no tiene por qué haber
diez hombres y una mujer,
ocho hombres y una mujer,
tiene que ser siempre,
cuatro y cuatro, tres y tres,
y si no las encuentras
tienes que seguir buscando,
para que haya un equilibrio.
Y además, como yo les digo
siempre a mis alumnos,
cuando hay más mujeres
que hombres,
debemos utilizar el femenino,
cuando hay más hombres
que mujeres,
utilizamos el masculino,
y no utilizar al varón como
la medida de las cosas.
La medida de todas las
cosas es todos nosotros,
el género humano, es la poesía.
Y vamos a comenzar por ahí.
Yo estaba esperando que iba a
tener aquí, no lo traje el --
¡oh!, déjeme decirle
algo que normalmente,
normalmente tenemos el libro de
la maratón preparado para cuando
se hace el maratón, este año
porque yo he aceptado un puesto,
extraordinario por un
lado y terrible por otro,
de jefe del departamento
en George Mason University.
George Mason, no
como me dijeron,
una chica publicó un
artículo en Rumanía,
diciendo que yo enseñaba en
Goerge Manson University,
[risas].
Y le escribí que, obviamente,
no le íbamos hacer ningún
homenaje a George Manson,
y se sintió muy mal, yo
le dije "no te preocupes,
otros crímenes ha habido
mucho más terribles que este",
[risas].
Pero uno tiene que estar abierto
también a reírse de uno mismo
que es el ejercicio.
La risa, la risa,
corrige la vida,
la poesía la corrige y la eleva,
y eso es lo que venimos
nosotros a celebrar acá.
Entonces, teniendo
en cuenta que --
que esta grabación
se está haciendo,
y que es importante que la gente
que vaya a ver sepa quién es la
persona que va a comenzar,
les voy a recomendar que cuando
ustedes lleguen la primera vez,
digan su nombre y el
país de donde vienen,
y después ya hagan las lecturas.
Una vez que se repitan las
lecturas no tienen que volver a
decir lo mismo, porque en la
grabación va a constar que usted
se llama Pedro Larrea
y que viene de España,
o Manuel Iris, etcétera, OK?
Y como vamos hacer esto, vamos
a invitar a los poetas y vamos a
leer dos poemas en
la primera ronda.
Vamos hacer una ronda.
Ustedes vienen se paran aquí,
dicen su nombre y de qué país
son, y después leen dos poemas.
Y después viene la
segunda persona,
y luego la tercera,
y luego la cuarta.
¿Eh?, una vez que
terminemos esa primera ronda,
yo voy a determinar si vamos
hacer una ronda de un poema más,
y después vamos a entrar en la
discusión que hacemos todos los
años, sobre ¿por
qué estamos aquí?,
¿cuál es la función de
la poesía en la vida?,
especialmente en estos momentos
de la historia de nuestro país y
del mundo en que parece que la
verdad ya no tiene lugar en la
tierra, y por eso el título
del libro de este año,
es "Viva es la voz
de la verdad",
que es un verso de una de las
poetas a quien celebramos este
año, Aída Cartagena Portalín,
una extraordinaria escritora
dominicana, grandísima poeta.
Y se celebra también
el centenario,
junto con el centenario de Aída,
del poeta español
Leopoldo de Luis,
otro poeta a quién yo tengo
un grandísimo aprecio,
porque a través de -- la
obra poética completa,
la obra poética de Miguel
Hernández que él publicó con su
hijo Jorge Urrutia en 1975,
fue que yo me aproximé a Miguel
Hernández que es el poeta que me
ha dado de comer, porque es el
poeta sobre el cual yo escribí
mi tesis de doctorado.
Quiere decir que a él le
debo mi carro, mi casa,
mi trabajo y encima a mi
mujer, y ahora, [risas],
y ahora a todos ustedes.
Gracias por estar
aquí, gracias Talia,
gracias colegas de la Biblioteca
del Congreso y gracias
compañeros de la
experiencia de estar vivos,
por aprovechar este momento
a venir a llenarse de poesía.
Y quiero poner como ejemplo a un
poeta que estuvo aquí hace dos
años, Tomás Modesto Galán,
que nos dijo "necesito recurrir
otra vez a la verdad de la
palabra poética, abandono Nueva
York y estaré en Washington con
los poetas".
Muchas gracias Tomás.
[ Aplausos ]
Vamos hacer una cosa, vamos
a comenzar así mismo, OK?
Plinio, Carlos, Manuel, Jorge,
Pedro y Milagros,
¿qué les parece?
He traído del libro
del año antepasado;
el libro del año
pasado, que lo tengo ahí,
lo voy a enseñar después;
y otros textos, pues,
para que simplemente
ustedes lo vean.
Plinio.
>> Plinio Chahín: ¿Qué tal?
Muchas gracias, buenas noches.
Plinio Chahín de Santo Domingo.
Dos poemas, voy a
leer un poema --
>> Rei Berroa: ¿Santo
Domingo, España?
>> Plinio Chahín: [Risas], Santo
Domingo de Neiba Yor [fonético].
Santo Domingo, República
Dominicana.
Hay una ciudad que se llama
Neiba, entonces, Neiba Yor.
Se llama "Noche", no
suelo titular los poemas,
pero este poema fue como
una especie de arrebato,
una noche, [risas].
¡Sí!, Rei, [risas],
me desperté con un insomnio
terrible, no podía dormir,
y el poema me salió así mismo,
no le corregí nada
absolutamente,
no había bebido nada señores,
[risa], por eso fue un arrebato.
"Entré cuanto más
apresurado pude salir,
pues a la entrada me advirtieron
que salía cuando yo pensé,
soñaba.
Si salí fue porque aquella noche
el crepúsculo fue ventana por
donde salí, ¿o acaso
entré?, a jugar en ella,
en esos rincones donde rara
vez se presenta la razón.
Los anónimos los amas tú,
retozan la mirada ahora en
nosotros que pasamos juntos,
en los ojos de los
otros que son nuestro,
objeto feliz de este absurdo
tan lógico pero inefable,
que por novísima vez
supuse sería esta la última,
pero en verdad fue la
primera noche en que la vi,
la deseé allí, en los ojos,
y todo resultó inefable,
inverosímil pero
tangible e inmaterial.
Condición del ser en la
conciencia del otro y la imagen
misma, producto de Safo
bailando el sofisma del sueño,
en los párpados meniáticos
de un poeta, amor de maniquí,
maniático en Safo, arlequín
de adoración del mí mismo,
donde ahora la amo".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
Fue un simple sueño romántico,
no era malos pensamientos,
[risas].
Entonces, este poema,
dice un poeta dominicano,
este poema estaba
tirado por el suelo.
Resulta que este poema,
desgraciadamente yo no
sé inglés, eso es --
aunque no por falta de
aplicación, [risas],
estudié diez niveles y
nunca logré aprenderlo.
Entonces, ya ustedes
pueden saber.
Oyendo un día a T.S. Eliot,
un amigo tiene un disco
de T.S. Eliot en inglés,
el ritmo me sedujo, me embrujó;
y oyendo el ritmo escribí este
poema, así mismo, sin corregir,
yo estoy hablando de estos
poemas, cuando yo tenía 24 años.
"Sin convicción no hay
principio ni final,
error que recordar cuando el
otro no lastima la existencia,
desde residuo inmóvil de
lo que aprendimos siempre,
y nunca olvidamos de memoria.
Así lo dijo Buda, 'ama al otro
en su necesidad primordial,
mas no lo juzgue en su agonía.
Reposa tus manos sobre él como
el fruto apetecido por el Dios
deseoso de solemnidad.
Pues, ¿qué culpa tiene
el que nunca existió,
y sin embargo le duele
la vida?'" Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Para
facilitar esto,
vamos a aplaudir cuando el
poeta termina su segundo poema,
hacemos un poema, y
después le aplaudimos,
porque hay siempre que
celebrar la poesía.
>> Carlos Velásquez
Torres: Buenas tardes,
yo soy Carlos Velásquez
Torres de Colombia, OK.
Este poema que voy a leer
tiene por título "AUC",
es la sigla de lo que en su
tiempo se llamó Autodefensas
Unidas de Colombia, el grupo
paramilitar que causó tantas
masacres y muertes
y dolor en Colombia.
"AUC. Será la sangre más fértil,
que la hierba en el desierto,
plagado de ruinas y de tumbas.
Los crucifijos son
pasto de ganados,
enajenados por el dolor
que escapó como alarido,
de las gargantas desgarradas
por el inmundo hierro de
los esbirros.
¿Quién será la peste que
nos libre del suplicio,
de la blasfemia, de
la mentira a gritos,
que proclama certidumbres tan
alocadas como el fragor de los
traidores en la tumba
de los caídos,
aun cuando la vergüenza
huye aterrada por los campos?
Miles de extravíos se regodean,
pero las puertas de emergencia
han sido clausuradas para evitar
una estampida.
¿Habrá más obscenidad que
presenciar impávidos el acto del
payaso sangriento que nos
aterró en la infancia.
El grotesco de la muerte cínico
se posa a nuestra diestra y su
carcajada hiela la
sangre del más temerario?
¡Oh! Corazón, ¿cómo he de
evitar que la agonía yazca
ridícula en la feria
estruendosa de mi cobardía,
y las palabras como ruedas
locas siquiera perturben
la insolencia?
He de abandonar mi voz o
lo que me queda de vida,
y que se disloque aún más
el estupor y la metralla,
el horizonte, la mirada y
yo en medio del infierno".
[ Pasando hojas de papel ]
Muy bien, este segundo poema,
es el poema que dio título
a uno de mis poemarios,
"Es de tontos el regreso",
yo se lo escribí a un amigo,
que no sé, la mayoría
lo conocen,
por lo menos los poetas,
Carlos Aguasaco, en Nueva York.
Cuando Carlos emigró, con
Carlos estudiamos juntos en la
universidad, los dos estudiamos
literatura, y Carlos emigró,
y yo vi que Carlos se fue
y se fue, y yo me quedé,
y el poema tiene como título
"Es de tontos el regreso".
OK. "Las cenizas de tu linaje
fueron barridas por una tormenta
colosal como la muerte,
y ese dolor te acompañará
más allá de tu memoria.
¿Qué de lo tuyo
quedó en la espera?,
no habrá juicio eterno que
devuelva los cimientos que la
tibieza de tu saga
sembró algún día,
ya ha acabado todo y si regresas
no será al solar de juegos,
ni a la morada que hubo
de guardar los aromas de
tu infancia.
Es de tontos el regreso,
cuando el camino fue borrado y
la tarde tiene el plomo fincado
en el horizonte y
ya no será más.
Deja que tus latidos
busquen el eco en la lejanía,
pues no hay sitio que te espere
y el compás del mundo enloquece
con el clamor de ausencias
que los muertos aúllan en
las noches.
No has de regresar ni siquiera,
has de repetir la travesía que
hubo de borrar las huellas,
sin despedida, la encrucijada
se plantó a tu espalda,
cuando la sangre abrió
la brecha de tu sendero.
Es de tontos fingir el regreso,
cuando el deseo se ha
peleado con la nostalgia,
deja tu camino y no te detengas,
que muchos tontos hemos de
verte aún en la lejanía".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Manuel Iris: Hola, ¿qué tal?
Mi nombre es Manuel Iris y
tengo el raro privilegio de
representar hoy a un
país y a una ciudad.
El país es México, y desde hace
más o menos dos meses la ciudad
de Cincinnati me nombró el
poeta laureado de la ciudad.
[Aplausos], entonces,
una cosa muy rara.
Y voy a leer dos poemas que
hablan precisamente de la
situación de estar
en dos sitios,
de siempre estar en otra parte,
como estamos los migrantes.
El primero se llama
"Soy de aquí".
"Uno es de los sitios
a los que ha llegado,
del idioma en el que no
puede soñar y un día sucede,
y se despierta preguntándose
cuál es su casa ahora,
cuando siempre hay
corazón en otra parte.
Uno proviene de las calles
que ya nunca son las mismas al
volver, proviene del momento en
el que decidió partir y de ese
otro en el que entiende
que todo se aleja.
Que es imposible
quedarse, aunque te quedes.
Que es imposible, aunque
regreses, regresar.
Escribo un verso que es como
una despedida y lo señalo:
soy de aquí".
[ Pasando hojas de papel ]
El otro poema no tiene título
y habla de una llamada por
teléfono con mi madre.
"Mi madre mira su
ventana y dice, "llueve".
Miro afuera realmente
está lloviendo dice,
cuando niño te buscabas
charcos para ver las nubes,
abro mi ventana y todo huele
como a sabor de jícama,
colgamos el teléfono salimos a
la puerta y sonreímos como si
viéramos la misma lluvia".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Jorge Galán: Hola,
buenas tardes,
soy Jorge Galán de El Salvador.
Voy a leer un solo poema,
porque es un poco extenso.
Y quiero explicarlo, ¿no?,
el título es "El chico
de la Cruz Verde".
La Cruz Verde es como la
Cruz Roja, es lo mismo, ¿no?
Entonces, cuando yo estaba
escribiendo un libro que se
llama "Medianoche del mundo",
leí la noticia de un muchacho
que había sido acribillado por
las pandillas.
En mi país, El Salvador,
quizás ustedes sabrán,
que es uno de los países
más peligrosos del mundo,
tenemos un problema de
violencia muy fuerte.
Y la historia de este
muchacho era que,
él vivía en una zona peligrosa
y había entrado a la Cruz Verde
como una manera de alejarse
de todo lo violento, ¿no?,
pero le fue imposible.
Y me conmovió mucho el hecho de
que le hubiera sido imposible,
como le es a la mayoría de
jóvenes de mi país alejarse de
la violencia, así que
escribí este poema.
"Querías escapar a través
de un camino que no existe.
Tus pequeños pies del tamaño
de puñados de abejas muertas
querían saltar sobre
los charcos,
o hacer equilibrio sobre
el reflejo de una cuerda,
pero caíste y tu cuerpo avanzó
hasta tu sombra para llenarla
como una pila bautismal
con agua bendita.
Fogatas frescas fueron las
frases que gritaste mientras
caías, agua encendida
sobre siete penumbras.
Todos sabemos que
vestías de verde,
que sobre el corazón alguien te
había cosido una cruz blanca,
que ibas con otros como tú
recogiendo los muertos como los
pescadores recolectan
peces inusitados,
que entraste en la claridad del
día en lugar de la oscuridad
bajo la cama, que viste un
aliento terrible convertirse en
tornado y luego en grito pero
que seguiste de pie incluso un
instante después
del último disparo.
Y que sigues de pie
para todos nosotros.
Sé que te acribillaron
al final de la tarde.
Y sé también que era
un juego de niños,
que fueron otros niños
los que te dispararon,
y que te conocían puesto que
te llamaron por tu nombre.
Y sé la calle en donde sucedió,
y sé el tamaño del horizonte
implacable bajo el que
aún persistes.
Los tiovivos no saben girar más.
Todas las madres menos una
se han tornado un sollozo.
Todas envejecieron menos esa
mujer cuyo lenguaje se ha vuelto
una lluvia de marzo, una nube
de cuervos se volvió su silueta.
14 aves de mal agüero cantaron
en la despiadada rama que el
viejo viento elude, esa rama
que solo florece en el invierno.
Niño más grande que la
plegaria en que persistes,
se ha secado el mar sobre
tu pupila aún abierta,
se han quebrado las sillas
de la cena de tus 15 años,
y de tus 16 y de tus 20,
los bosques se han
derrumbado sobre sus troncos,
y todo ha callado
un minuto terrible,
los rostros han caído como el
hacha de piedra sobre el cuello
de la gacela, y se
ha acabado el día.
Siete balas como
siete maldiciones,
como siete tornados
súbitos asaltaron tu cuerpo.
Siete leonas grises
para una sola presa.
Y derrotaron tu hermosa
voluntad.
Y hablaron al oído de cada uno
de nosotros para decirnos la
verdad sobre todas las cosas,
para advertirnos que estamos
solos otra vez y mostrarnos el
final de un camino que
no comienza nunca".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Pedro Larrea Rubio: Buenas
tardes, me llamo Pedro Larrea,
soy español, originario de
Madrid y adoptivo de Virginia,
Estado Unidos.
Hoy en la Biblioteca del
Congreso de los Estados Unidos,
quiero dedicar esta
lectura a Engracia Mariscal,
una persona a quien conocí
en una nueva orilla libre
del corazón.
"Cuando mueves las manos me
enseñas a blandir tulipanes.
Esa dosis de armisticio
que propagan tus uñas,
es una escuela de cómo
domar dromedarios.
Quiero dibujar tus dedos pero
ya están trazados por delfines o
por la lluvia que espolvorea
semillas de yuca sobre el jardín
salvaje de un llanto
incomprendido.
Cuando mueves las manos combates
el hambre y te reconozco en tu
postura de ninja durmiente,
de húsar que ofrece su
espada a un sintecho.
Eres una valkiria que toca una
tuba oxidada en la terraza de un
sórdido rascacielos.
Aunque alimentan, nadie sabe
entender tus yemas todavía.
Cuando mueves las manos entran
en ritmo las sonrisas de toda
una ciudad en donde importan.
Tienes algo indescriptible
en los nudillos,
algo así como bongos olvidados
en la jungla pero más profundo:
quizá el cuero de
una darbuca abisal.
Hay artefactos que no comprendo
sin que tú los hagas música.
De pronto tus manos
no se mueven.
Sé que descansas, que ahora
no vas a crear más dulces
conflictos y que después
atenderás a los quiromantes.
Mientras, yo vigilo tus
guantes y difundo tu sueño.
Cuando no mueves las
manos petrificas koalas.
Te esperaré batiendo
palmas y forjando anillos".
"No hay nada como verter un
cubilite de azahar sobre tu
blusa, abrirte el balcón y
anunciarte que aún no ha llegado
el correo de las islas.
No hay nada como hacerte ver
que un nómada te sostiene la
sombrilla cuando vas a remojarte
los pies a la charca con luna.
No hay nada como tener
celos de un vestido.
No hay nada como escoltarte a
la bañera y abrirte el tarro de
sales y algas.
Nada como alcanzarte la toalla
que ayer te plancharon las
sirenas chipriotas.
No hay nada como tenderte
una mano y que la tomes.
No hay nada como
cerrar los ojos y verte.
No. No hay nada que nos falte,
nada que se nos olvidara
en la costa.
No hay nada como ensartar todo
lo nuestro en un collar de
minutos para el cuello
de la esfinge,
nada como un vaso de
zumo de nuestro tiempo.
No hay nada que se resista a
nuestra doble soledad en punto.
Sí lo hay.
Hay pensar que en el solsticio
de mañana nos habremos olvidado
de acordarnos, y que a
partir de esta noche faltarán
constelaciones para que
no sepamos reinventar
la madrugada".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Milagros Terán:
Buenas tardes,
me llamo Milagros Terán,
y soy de Nicaragua.
Por lo general siempre
leo de blanco,
pero hoy estoy de negro
porque estoy de luto,
por la situación de
mi país, de Nicaragua.
Hoy ya son 137 los muertos,
los estudiantes nicaragüenses
que han sido masacrados por el
régimen de Daniel Ortega y su
Vicepresidenta Rosario Morillo.
Voy a leer hoy de
mi primer poemario,
son poemas que hice en
las décadas de los 20,
porque es como siente
mi corazón hoy.
"Invitación al canto.
Que los días oscuros
no me dobleguen,
no puedan conmigo las
trampas bajo los cocoteros,
que el horror de las noches,
el olor a sudor y heces,
no distraiga el paso
del regocijo.
Vengan garzas, a beber en mis
pozas profundas de vitrinas,
vengan a cantar todas las
musas alborotadas de soledad,
llenen de fotos los rincones,
se amontonen bajo los cocoteros,
a ahuyentar este tiempo
banal, tiempo de muertos".
"Adiós a Sarayevo [fonético].
La puesta en marcha, el bautismo
de fuego, el adiós a Sarayevo,
la mochila sucia a ras del piso,
bajo el asiento del autobús,
la humedad de sus manos,
adherida a la ventanilla fría
como el alma -- no veo -- .
Real como la guerra, sucia
como el pecado y su impotencia,
sin colores alegres, sólo el
gris de los ojos y el verde de
los uniformes.
Otra vez la impotencia,
la frustración,
el desapacible rechinar
de dientes,
las fotos de lo que
fue mi ciudad infantil,
la que ya nadie podrá
devolverme,
los discursos vacíos y el
autobús rodando sobre el fango,
dejando atrás las
voces fantasmagóricas,
el miedo a las trincheras,
la lumbre del hogar,
el bautismo de fuego,
la tormenta".
[Aplausos].
>> Plinio Chahín: Bueno yo pensé
que Modesto [inaudible] iba
a leer.
Disculpa un momento.
Voy a leer dos poemitas breves.
>> Rei Berroa: [Inaudible] dos
poemas breves ahora y luego
hacemos la discusión
[inaudible].
>> Plinio Chahín: Sí.
Hay un poeta, murió ya,
que yo tuve la dicha de
conocer y tratar varias veces,
junto a un amigo poeta
dominicano que ha venido aquí
varias veces, José
Mármol, Roberto Guarro.
Y, bueno, un poco influido
por esa poesía, ontológica,
vamos a decir, existencial,
escribí estos textos,
un grupo de textos.
"Tantísimo rostro hay como
uno lo recuerda a todos,
ninguno puede haber como
el que ha existido siempre,
aunque yo jamás he visto uno,
todo parecido es imposible".
Y este otro, bajo la influencia
de esa poesía vertical.
"Los que no se han encontrado
aún, están eternamente juntos,
aunque se conozcan, como
si nunca hubiesen existido,
pues jamás olvida, quien
ha olvidado siempre".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Carlos Velásquez
Torres: Bueno,
voy a buscar aquí algo breve,
[pasando hojas de papel].
[Inaudible].
Estoy buscando algo breve.
>> Rei Berroa: [Inaudible]
no importa [inaudible].
>> Carlos Velásquez Torres: Ya
va un segundito, se me perdió.
Siempre me pasa.
Bueno, vamos a -- este que
es el primero que aparece.
"Amanecer.
Sigue gastando tu tiempo
al esperar la aurora,
crees que con sus llegadas,
se borraran de un soplo
tus recientes pesadillas,
y el terror nocturno
que sobrevino al día,
será disipado por las tempranas
luces que nublarán el alba.
Cada minuto que le entregas a
la vana espera te será cobrado,
cuando tu vida, la
poca que te queda,
se disuelva en el trasegar
[fonético] del desengaño,
pues no hay más pecado que
esperar el regreso de los
muertos o la justicia poética de
los viejos cuando la suerte nos
ha desterrado de su lado.
Olvida ya esa extraña manía de
aguardar silente en la mañana,
es posible que mientras llega,
tus ojos se nublen por
resplandores que enceguecen y el
monótono silencio se transforme
en estridencias con la velocidad
aterradora con que la duermevela
engaña a quienes se desviven por
el sueño.
Puedes quedar absorto o imbécil,
o acabar tu vida
como inútil vigía,
mientras los mercaderes de la
miseria agigantan la usura y tu
deuda crece y se hace impagable.
No malgastes el tiempo,
pues no te pertenece,
pronto vendrán a
cambiarlo por tu sangre,
venderán tus miembros
y tus pocas miserias,
y el silencio de la ruina
se convertirá en mañana".
Bueno.
[ Pasando hojas de papel ]
OK. Este otro poema tiene como
título "Farewell [fonético]".
[Inaudible].
Farewell, ¿es mejor?, OK.
>> Rei Berroa: Es
por la grabación.
>> Carlos Velásquez
Torres: ¡Ah!
OK. Bueno, "Farewell".
"Ha llegado el momento
que tanto ansiabas,
empieza tu camino y aprovecha
cada truco y cada giro del azar.
Olvida lo que soñaste
y conviértete,
transforma tu carne
en mercancía,
no has de encontrar
de mí reproche alguno,
ni la sutileza de
un suspiro quedo,
ni el roce de una efímera mirada
intercederá por tu pasado,
ya lo has conseguido, acomoda tu
marcha al gigantesco desfile de
almas en pena, y acompasa tus
latidos al largo y rutinario
obstinato, ritmo cansino de los
millones que ha convertido el
orgullo en un pan
rancio pero seguro.
Mantén, sin embargo,
la fluidez de tu verso,
no hayas de mostrar la verdadera
profundidad de tus palabras,
pues el sueño se romperá y
un raudal de miserias será
tu castigo.
Repite orgulloso sus salmos,
sus cantos, sus himnos,
marcha altivo y esconde el
vacío que en tus ojos dejó el
horizonte tras la despedida,
vete pues sin miedo,
y no sigas acaso mi recuerdo,
ya vienen por ti y aun no has
mudado ese ensueño nocivo que
algún día se posó en tu mirada".
[ Aplausos ]
>> Manuel Iris: Voy a leer
dos breves poemas de amor.
Hace también dos meses
me convertí en papá.
So, [aplausos], el primero va a
ser de esa clase de amor, ¿no?
Testigo.
>> Rei Berroa:
Eso es maravilloso,
la próxima vez, mamá.
[ Risas ]
>> Manuel Iris: Me la
pones difícil Rei, [risas].
Haré lo que pueda.
"Testigo. 'Está bailando
tu hija', dice mi esposa,
y se toca la barriga, desde hace
cinco meses soy testigo de lo
que sucede ahí, debajo
de sus manos,
mi esposa es una casa dentro de
mi casa y yo estoy fuera de mi
propio corazón.
Seguro está contenta, dice,
y yo sería capaz de renunciar
a la poesía a cambio de tener
dentro de mí a mi hija,
de sentir esa danza que las
une a todos los principios.
Pero la opción no existe y
hago lo que puedo, cocinar,
solucionar antojos, escribir un
poema en el que digo lo que veo
desde este lado de la piel en
que se encarna el misterio y
testimonio con amorosa envidia
que un milagro muchas veces
repetido es un milagro,
y nada menos".
Y en el tema del amor y
un poco de la infancia,
este poema que se llama
"Hacia una posible
explicación del amor.
Para Claudia Vélez.
La niña que tú fuiste me saluda
desde el fondo de tus 30 años,
y el niño que yo fui le
corresponde, emocionado.
Amar es descuidarse y dejar que
los niños que hemos sido salgan
a jugar juntos y que luego
regresen felices y sucios a
mostrarnos hojas
y piedras únicas.
El niño que yo fui quiere salir
al patio de la casa en la que
fuiste niña, y jugar
en la lluvia, contigo.
A veces, mientras
caminamos juntos,
ellos también se
toman de la mano".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Jorge Galán: Bueno,
voy a leer un poema muy,
muy antiguo pero que le tengo
un cariño bastante especial.
Se llama "Miniatura asombrosa".
"Alguien puso semillas en
mi mano, 30 árboles mañana,
tanto bosque ciento
de años más tarde,
aves encontrarán el
sur en esos árboles,
y los lobos encontrarán cobijo,
y las hormigas crecerán como un
cuerpo entre las raíces ciegas
y soñolientas.
Y alguna vez una
casa y otra casa,
construirán esas maderas y el
invierno bajará en sedimentos,
y el otoño con su total hastío
pondrá sus pies pesados sobre
sus troncos gruesos
y nos los vencerá.
Nada hará que se quiebren.
Y dentro de 100 años,
100 hombres,
serán hombres felices amando
sus mujeres bajo esos techos
amplios, un perfume de voz que
flotará todavía en los hijos
que lleguen.
El mundo será el mundo
y la noche la noche,
las lechuzas de entonces tendrán
ojos más grandes y como harán
gorriones, lo mismo
que alacranes.
Y el ratón será mínimo
como un insecto extraño,
su pálida pelambre lo volverá
invisible de noviembre a febrero
y no tendrá enemigo, ni
el águila, ni el hombre,
si acaso la serpiente.
30 árboles mañana, flores malvas
y rojas creciendo en ese bosque,
ayer, unas semillas que alguien
puso en mi mano y que yo lancé
al cielo".
Y este que se llama
"Race horse",
que tiene un nombre
en inglés, y bueno,
no recuerdo porque lo puse así,
pero -- así quedó, [risas].
También es un poema un
poco -- de hace tiempo.
"Y mira tú, muchacha, de
quién viniste a enamorarte,
a quién viniste a amar
para toda la vida,
a quién decidiste no olvidar:
es un caballo de carreras,
ese muchacho es un caballo de
carreras y corre siempre junto a
la barda colmada por espinos y
sus músculos inflamados siempre
a punto de reventarse.
¿Quién lo conduce?
Sus estribos son ríos a
los cuales muerde para
intentar romper.
Sus ojos ven un horizonte de
fuego al que no puede dejar
de dirigirse.
Sus cascos son de un cristal
incorruptible que aniquila a
la piedra.
Su crin es el viento
azotado por el relámpago.
Una tormenta tiene donde
debió tener un breve corazón,
una tormenta a la cual teme
incluso el invierno mismo.
Su imaginación es la misma que
la de la montaña y la del grito
que corta el silencio
de la montaña desolada.
No es de fiar.
¿Quién confiaría su
alma a una tormenta?
¿Quién brindaría su piel al
cuchillo de fuego o su voz al
silencio de la flauta
quebrada por el odio?
Y mira tú, muchacha dulce,
te abriste como un cofre lleno
de perlas que parecían brotar de
la luz misma y él ni
siquiera pudo notarlo,
él es un caballo de carreras y
no le importa ni la ciudad ni el
camino que lleva a la ciudad ni
las joyas ni un cuello lleno de
joyas ni un cofre
lleno de joyas,
solo le importa el bosque y
el campo abierto y la playa
interminable, pero
sobre todo, la pista,
esa pista de grama,
arena y piedra.
Y mira tú de quién
viniste a enamorarte,
a quién quisiste guardar en
ti como un corazón nuevo,
a quién quisiste abrazar
hasta perder los brazos,
a quién quisiste mirar
hasta cerrar tanto los ojos,
que no consigues ya
observar la dicha.
Mira tú, muchacha linda,
a quién quisiste amar,
a un obstinado caballo
de carreras cuya pista es
el mundo".
[ Aplausos ]
>> Pedro Larrea Rubio: "Mordiste
una granada y en tus dientes
quedó la sangre presa para
esculpir anillos sobre estas
piedras suaves de mis hombros.
Maceraste un limón entre tus
labios para empapar mi piel con
su pulpa de estrella y así
apurar el jugo azul del poro.
Hundiste tus encías en las
ascuas de un gajo de naranja que
en el panal de lenguas me
incendió el paladar hasta
el rescoldo.
Y cuando abandonaba la viña
incandescente de tu cuerpo se me
quedó la carne enfrutecida".
Y el último poema que voy
a leer, también corto,
me trae a mis días de
la infancia en Madrid,
yo he vivido toda
mi época adulta,
toda mi edad adulta
en los Estados Unidos,
pero recuerdo que
vivía en Madrid,
mi lugar de origen en
una comunidad de vecinos,
una corrala antigua, donde tenía
unos vecinos fascinantes a quien
echo de menos, pero que
siempre van conmigo.
Estaba Don Miguel, el manco,
veterano de la guerra, ¿no?,
que estuvo toda su vida pidiendo
un trabajo al gobierno y jamás
se lo dio, acabó escribiendo
una novela, para sobrevivir,
tampoco le dio de comer.
También está Don Francisco de
Quevedo, ¿no?, el cascarrabias,
¿no?, [risas], era el rico
del edificio y se dedicaba a
comparar las casas y los pisos
de los poetas enemigos para
dejarlos en la calle, como fue
el caso del pobre Don Luis que
se tuvo que ir a vivir
al barrio de al lado,
porque tenía una
sobrina que le acogió.
Pero de todos los vecinos,
el que siempre me acompaña,
el que habla cuando hablaba mi
abuela, cuando hablaba mi madre,
cuando hablaba no
maldecía mis amigos,
cuando todas las Españas se
encontraban en Madrid y hablaban
al mismo tiempo, y quiero
dedicar este poema a ese vecino
que nunca me abandona.
Lo llamamos en Madrid,
simplemente nos referimos
a él como Lope,
todo el mundo lo
conocemos, ¿ah?,
y más allá de las fronteras,
a la gente le gusta llamarle,
muy rimbombantemente, don Félix
Lope de Vega y Carpio, [risas].
>> Rei Berroa: Fénix
de los [inaudible].
>> Pedro Larrea Rubio:
Fénix de los ingenios,
monstruo de la naturaleza,
[risas].
Este poema está basado en uno
de Lope de las rimas humanas.
"Me conozco mejor
cuando me besas,
cuando no sé pedirte
que me dejes.
Me besas y me salgo de los ejes,
nos callamos y ya
no quedan fresas.
Me besas y no sabes que me
besas hasta que yo te beso,
no me dejes fuera de las
estrellas que destejes.
Están tus uñas rojas
pero ilesas.
Me conozco mejor cuando
me muerdes en ese músculo
del cuello.
Sabes donde me gusta
sin que lo recuerdes.
No te despegues, no
escupas, no acabes,
que aún nuestras costillas están
verdes y esto es amor por mucho
que te laves".
[ Risas ]
[ Aplausos ]
>> Milagros Terán: Bueno,
ahora voy a leer de mi libro más
reciente, que acaba de salir,
pero antes quiero dar las
gracias al profesor y poeta Rei
Berroa, por este trabajo
que hace cada año de amor,
de tener este maratón
de la poesía.
La primera vez que participé fue
hace 22 años y recuerdo que fue
en este mismo salón,
y que estaba embarazada
de mi hija Victoria.
O sea, que leí -- ¿Ah?
[Inaudible].
Sí, porque hoy tengo aquí mis
dos hijos varones, que vinieron,
uno que vino de Nicaragua,
por esta situación
en la que estamos;
y mi hijo que vive
en Filadelfia,
y la novia de Federico.
Así es que, voy a leer dos
poemas de este libro más
reciente que se llama "Lejos",
que escribí cuando estaba
viviendo en África y
en Brasil.
Bueno, este poema que
voy a leer dedicado a los
jóvenes centroamericanos.
"Caracol. La odisea del náufrago
que sueña cada noche con el
camino a casa, y vuelve y la
encuentra azotada y su cama
ocupada, y sus hijos
dispersos por el mundo.
El joven que buscando futuro se
sube a un tren y viaja al aire
libre bajo el sol, con el sueño
de una libertad prometida,
sentado en el techo del vagón
que va de frente y que no
se detiene.
Hoy soñé que era un caracol,
y que andaba mi casa sobre la
espalda, era grande mi concha,
voluptuosa, la llevaba orgullosa
sobre el lomo fuerte de molusco.
Donde paro, la monto,
la preparo,
la limpio de vestigios de arena.
Donde paro, me zambullo
como pez al océano.
Donde paro, la tiendo
y me refugio".
"La pérdida.
La pérdida es un hoyo,
un pedazo que falta,
el hijo que está lejos,
la hermana ausente,
los amigos, el español.
La pérdida es el tiempo
abierto y enemigo,
las fauces que me esperan,
la desidia, el desgano,
la flacidez de músculos
en descanso.
La pérdida es el
incumplimiento de promesas,
la carta no escrita, la lista de
compras que aguarda en la mesa,
la llamada pérdida.
La pérdida es el
sueño que se escapa,
el miedo en la madrugada, el
constante ladrido de los perros.
La pérdida es la falta de
un lenguaje que nos una,
la flacidez que mata
al gusano de seda".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Bueno, vamos a
entrar ahora en un capítulo,
diferente al capítulo en el cual
hemos estado durante esta hora
que acabamos de celebrar.
Y lo que yo quisiera hacer
en este momento es un poco de
reflexión relacionada con la
experiencia de la palabra.
La experiencia de la palabra que
nos hace sentir y que nos hace
vibrar inevitablemente
como seres humanos.
Hace unos días en una entrevista
estábamos conversando,
un poeta colombiano y
un poeta norteamericano,
en una entrevista que
hicimos en Manazas,
y nos pusimos hablar sobre la
experiencia que cada uno de
nosotros tiene de la
poesía como un hobby.
Es decir, cada uno de nosotros
inevitablemente sabe que sin la
poesía, es decir,
sin la capacidad de
utilizar las palabras,
atadas a un ritmo particular,
pero sobre todo manifestando ese
río de experiencias que cada uno
de ustedes ha traído aquí;
cada uno de nosotros sabe que
sin esa inevitable posibilidad
de humanidad, nosotros
no estaríamos,
nos sentiríamos como seres
vacíos, porque además,
ninguno de nosotros
vive de la poesía.
Y es ahí a donde
yo quiero entrar,
comenzar la discusión porque a
mí lo que me interesa ahora es
ver como todos ustedes,
no solamente los
poetas que están aquí,
sino a todos aquellos ustedes
que tienen la experiencia de
leer, no de twittear, sino
de leer específicamente,
con esto hablan sobre la
posibilidad de entenderse como
seres frágiles, pero
al mismo tiempo,
todos nosotros con un deseo
absoluto de tener los pies en la
tierra y la cabeza realmente
donde tiene que estar.
Maya Angelou, la
poeta extraordinaria,
que fue invitada cuando Bill
Clinton fue elegido presidente a
leer un poema, la maravilla
de tener ciertas personas que
piensan en la necesidad
de traer la poesía,
y esa práctica la comenzó,
como ustedes saben,
J.F.K con Robert Frost.
Maya Angelou en una entrevista
en un programa indicaba que
había recibido un tiempo
en White Frost University
[fonético], le ofrecieron
un puesto de por vida para
enseñar poesía.
Y entonces ella bromeaba,
porque decía "este es un
regalo increíble, es decir,
incluso si yo llegara
a ser senil,
todavía tendría la posibilidad
de recibir un salario por mi
factura como poeta".
Y yo quiero comenzar por ahí.
¿En qué forma esa posibilidad
que tiene Maya Angelou de
recibir un puesto en
White Frost University,
de enseñar poesía de por vida
es una celebración de la poesía?
Y, al mismo tiempo, ¿de qué
manera cada uno de nosotros
busca de alguna forma
celebrar la poesía,
asegurándose de que no falta esa
celebración en los momentos que
le toca estar aquí
en la tierra?,
¿de qué manera celebra
esto la poesía?
¿Eh? Todo el que quiera
decir -- , cuidado, ¿no?,
yo no quiero que ustedes
crean que esta es una forma de
obligarles a ustedes a canalizar
lo que quieran decir a través de
lo que yo digo.
Esto es simplemente una
forma de romper el hielo, OK?
Decir, que si usted quiere
venir y tocar este tema,
pues muy bien, y sino a mí lo
que me interesa es que todos
nosotros vengamos aquí a decir
algo extraordinario sobre la
experiencia de la palabra.
Fíjense que ustedes se han
olvidado completamente de los
teléfonos y de twittear durante
este tiempo que han estado aquí,
¿por qué?, ¿a qué se debe eso?
Esta es otra celebración de
la poesía, ¿cómo celebramos?,
¿cómo celebran ustedes
la experiencia poética?
Todo el que quiera decir
algo tiene que venir aquí,
porque yo quiero que también eso
esté en las grabaciones que se
van a hacer, OK?
Venga, la puerta está abierta.
Sí, Modesto.
>> Modesto: [Inaudible] palabra.
>> Rei Berroa: Ven, ven
para acá, para que --
>> Modesto: Sí, cuando escucho
al maestro Rei Berroa hablando y
-- me siento -- aumenta
mi timidez.
>> Rei Berroa: Entonces,
no, [risas].
>> Modesto: Pero también cuando
escucho esta pléyade de poetas,
yo sabía que había dado un paso
positivo al emigrar de Nueva
York hasta acá, porque iba
a sobrevivir al tiempo que
nosotros estamos viviendo ahora.
Esa sensación de estar
escuchando algo no usual,
es lo que me hace feliz.
Y el escuchar experiencias
de las vidas de muchos seres
humanos, evidenciada con
tanto encanto y con tanta
originalidad, y gracia que
había una mujer en el grupo,
que resume las otras
que faltaron.
Este momento ha sido inédito,
esa es la palabra, inédito.
Yo creo cuando -- yo disfruto el
momento previo a la poesía y la
poesía en sí misma, cuando el
poeta está hablando de lo que va
a leer, yo percibo
otra cosa, otro texto.
Como me pasó hace un rato con
Yanet que me hablaba del mundo
negro con el que ella se
encontró en un momento
determinado, yo encuentro un
mundo en cada uno de ustedes.
Y esa, en la intertextualidad,
en la narrativa,
porque también eso me
fascina, ustedes --
este es un gran momento.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Buenas tardes, para mí
la poesía es desahogo y es
celebración de la experiencia
humana hecha sentimientos,
y poder profundizar en nuestros
dolores y en nuestras alegrías,
y en la universalidad que
existe en ese sentir, ¿no?,
en esa humanidad que todos
tenemos dentro y que no todos
tenemos el valor de poner
en palabras y ante el mundo.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Ya, no todos,
no todos tenemos la
capacidad de poder --
y esta es la cosa
extraordinaria de la poesía,
que la poesía transmite los
sentimientos, que todos tenemos,
pero que no todos somos
capaces de hacer visual,
o hacer audible a través
del uso de las palabras.
Sí, Manuel.
>> Manuel Iris: Contra
natura trataré de ser breve.
Yo siempre hablo mucho, [risa].
A pesar de que, desde
que nací soy breve.
[ Risas ]
Yo creo, espero no
sonar proselitista,
pero yo creo que la poesía
es un derecho humano.
Yo creo que la poesía
es necesaria de verdad,
como el aire y como el
agua y como la comida.
Y yo creo que la poesía,
la expresión artística tanto
hacerla como disfrutarla,
son un derecho humano,
porque sin eso uno no está
desarrollando sus capacidades
enteras como ser humano, hay una
parte que nos falta cuando eso
no está allí.
Y yo creo que es responsabilidad
de todo mundo, de todo mundo,
de los maestros y de los padres
y de los bibliotecarios y de los
vecinos, y de los
amigos, y de todo mundo,
poner un poco de
belleza en el mundo,
agregarle algo a la poesía.
Yo creo -- agregarle
algo al mundo,
yo creo que la poseía es un acto
de justicia porque cuando el
mundo es horrible, uno tiene que
responder con belleza porque es
lo único que podemos hacer;
y cuando el mundo es bello,
uno tiene que contestar
con belleza,
porque es bueno agradecer.
No debe existir otra opción
que contestar con belleza.
Debemos siempre recurrir a
la belleza contra el mundo,
debemos siempre recurrir a
la belleza a favor del mundo.
Entonces, yo creo de verdad,
que la poesía es un derecho
humano y que ahora mismo,
cuando estamos tan acostumbrados
a que todo se individualiza,
se individualiza el
timbre del celular,
se individualiza la foto de
Facebook, se individualiza todo,
y todo mundo quiere ser único,
la poesía nos recuerda todo
lo que tenemos en común,
nos recuerda que no somos tan
distintos y que ser distinto no
es tan importante.
Es importante saber que
somos mucho de lo mismo.
Es importante saber
que el primero amor,
es el primer amor desde
primer homínido que amó.
Es importante saber que
el hambre es el hambre,
que el odio es el odio y ahora
mismo cuando se pone tanto
énfasis en nuestras diferencias
yo creo que es necesario que
recordemos ese derecho humano,
de estar unidos por lo
que tenemos de igual,
que es casi todo.
La poesía se encarga de eso.
Yo creo que la poesía
se encarga,
no hermanarnos sino de
recordarnos que ya éramos
hermanos desde antes.
Creo entonces, y termino
repitiendo mi primera frase,
yo creo que la poesía es un
derecho humano y que por lo
tanto hay que defenderlo,
¿no?, en eso estamos.
Gracias. [Inaudible].
Sí.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Pedro Larrea Rubio:
Es muy común que al poeta o al
escritor le pregunten al final o
al principio de una lectura qué
es la poesía o qué es para ese
autor la poesía.
A mí con esa pregunta me pasa lo
mismo que le ocurría a Leopoldo
Alas Clarín con el matrimonio.
Leopoldo Alas Clarín decía que
la gente no debía casarse hasta
el final de su vida, o
sea, salida a la muerte.
Dos parejas están juntas,
viven una vida feliz de
la vida 50 años juntos,
¡qué maravilloso!, vamos a
casarnos y ya nos morimos juntos
y nos vamos casados, [risas].
Es decir, es decir, no se
puede firmar el contrato de la
felicidad o hacer la
profecía de la felicidad,
sin saber lo que va a venir,
y no hay que preocuparse
por ello, [risas].
La poesía es un poco igual en
el sentido de que el mundo --
bueno, estamos en la
Biblioteca del Congreso,
estamos rodeados de libros, hay
millones y millones de libros.
El encuentro íntimo de un lector
con un libro no necesariamente
es poesía, no necesariamente
todos los libros de poesía o de
poemas, mejor dicho, son poesía.
Pero, ese encontronazo,
porque es un topetazo como de la
cabeza de un mulo, de un toro,
¿no?, esa chispa puede
salir, y eso es poesía.
También es muy común hablar de
la poesía como algo muy elevado,
¿no?, y todas esas
definiciones son necesarias.
Antes ha comentado Manuel,
es un derecho humano,
es una inmanencia,
de todos nosotros;
pero también me gustaría
recordar algunos casos de
escritores y poetas fabulosos,
tan fabulosos que
son ya estereotipos,
en los que se desmintió
un poco esa grandiosidad o
grandilocuencia de la poesía,
porque la poesía es algo humano,
¿no?, y humano quiere
decir cotidiano.
Recuerdo en el caso de William
Shakespeare, por ejemplo,
recuerdo entrevisté hace un
par de años a Harold Bloom,
profesor de la Universidad de
Yale, experto en Shakespeare,
a parte de su idiosincrasia
peculiar,
pero un gran shakespeariano;
y él decía "es curioso que cada
vez que me encuentro un libro de
Shakespeare, es casi
sobre Shakespeare, ¿no?,
un libro académico
de algún experto,
es inevitable leer páginas y
páginas sobre la grandeza de
Shakespeare, sobre todo lo que
Shakespeare nos ha enseñado y
cómo maneja el lenguaje.
Y lo que prácticamente no se dan
cuenta es que Shakespeare era --
no había estudiado en
la universidad, ¿no?,
algo raro para un autor letrado
de la época y el padre de
Shakespeare era guantero, era
un fabricante de guantes".
Eso significa que tenía un
taller en el que por el cual
pasaban -- y esto era
rarísimo en la época -
pasaban gente de todas
las clases sociales,
desde los aristócratas,
hasta los poceros.
Porque también había no
sólo guantes de seda,
sino también había
guantes de esparto.
Entonces, en esa época en las
que las clases estaban tan
separadas y los discursos, por
tanto también eran paralelos,
Shakespeare pudo escuchar
perfectamente al aristócrata,
¿no?, noble de la Corte
Isabelina como al panadero de
Statford [fonético],
y esa mezcla,
esa mezcolanza de palabras,
ese enfrentamiento con
la realidad mezclada,
es lo que creo que genera
una cotidianidad que puede
ser poesía.
Antes hablaba de Lope de Vega,
Lope de Vega sigue siendo
tan moderno para nosotros,
nos sigue sonando y es
muy querido, ¿por qué?,
mi abuela no sabía
escribir y leer,
pero mi abuela hablaba
como Lope de Vega, a veces,
no siempre claro, pero --
, [risas], sino habríamos
sido ricos en la familia,
pero de vez en cuando, de cada
diez frases que decía a lo mejor
era un simple refrán que ni
siquiera era de invención suya
una asociación de palabras por
su rapidez al hablar lo que sea
que de repente, [inaudible]
del lenguaje,
esas palabras que están
ahí, está todo ahí,
la materia de la
poesía está ahí,
pero la poesía no sucede
siempre, es el encuentro.
Y a veces, esperemos en un
poema escrito dentro de un libro
de poesía.
Eso es más o menos.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Plinio Chahín: Yo al igual
que mi compatriota, soy tímido,
pero al oír la palabra
de mí amigo aquí.
Y bueno, Harold Bloom decía que
Shakespeare en realidad había
inventado la vida, el
libro de él se llama
"La invención de lo humano".
O sea, el poeta,
partiendo de esa idea,
el poeta para mí es el
que crea nueva visiones,
funda otra realidad,
mundos nuevos, no descubre,
la parte más oscura, más
perversa del ser humano.
El poeta a través de la
poesía, del lenguaje,
como expresión fundamental,
en realidad lo que hace es
inventar una nueva vida.
Y a propósito de eso, yo
creo que definir la poesía es
un imposible.
Un imposible creíble, como decía
[inaudible] porque en el momento
en que se define la poesía, en
el momento de definir la poesía,
se disuelve en sí misma.
Sucede que -- hay
una frase famosa,
una anécdota que está en la
confesión de San Agustín,
decía "si me preguntaran qué es
el tiempo, no sabría qué decir,
ahora si no me lo preguntan
sé lo que es el tiempo".
Yo creo que un poco pasa
con la poesía eso, [risas],
si no me preguntan
lo que es la poesía,
yo sé lo que es la poesía,
ahora si me la preguntan --
>> Rei Berroa: Estoy perdido.
>> Plinio Chaín: Estoy perdido.
Entonces, yo creo que la
poesía simplemente es,
no significa como
decía Archibald McLean,
el poeta norteamericano.
Por eso cuando tú hablabas,
y recuerden que yo
vengo del caribe,
y los caribeños todos
somos un poco esquizoides,
fragmentados, [risas].
Sí, sí, anoté por eso,
estas breves palabras,
cuando tú hablabas de la poesía,
como el oficio que uno puede
vivir, nadie vive de la poesía,
sería un milagro realmente.
Claro a excepción de los
escritores profesionales,
y ahí se perdería todo riesgo
cuando uno se convierte en
profesional, se pierde todo
riesgo, porque no hay aventura,
el escritor debe ser
siempre un aficionado,
un hombre que aprende
cuando escribe,
siempre la experiencia
es virgen, siempre.
Y era la gran idea de Mallarmé,
escribía un poema y lo que
estaba era reescribiéndolo,
volvía, quería por eso
escribir el poema perfecto;
es decir que la poesía, que
el mundo, acabara en un libro.
Bueno, si viviera en
esta época, [risas],
tuviera en crisis ese
pensamiento, porque en realidad,
la realidad -- el mundo no
va a terminar en un libro,
va a terminar en una
computadora, en el internet.
Ahora, ya lo importante
no es el medio,
sino que son los soportes,
los diferentes soportes.
Y en ese sentido, creo que
la poesía es un milagro.
A propósito, como uno no vive
de la poesía, yo escribí aquí,
"uno no vive de la poesía,
uno vive para la
poesía y por el poema".
Uno de la poesía se sirve
para inventar la poesía,
que es la vida.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Carlos Velásquez
Torres: Bueno,
yo creo que esta discusión
empezó ayer un poco en la --
allá en Teatro la
Luna, ¿no?, ayer.
Y yo quería decir que -- en mi
experiencia personal, o sea,
en la eterna verdad en la que
vivo, porque es mi experiencia,
o sea, el universo
vive aquí en mí,
nosotros compartimos
muchas cosas,
pero la verdad está
en mí, ¡qué pena!,
es la única verdad
que conozco, ¿no?
Pero más allá de esto que puede
parecer un poco egocéntrico,
de verdad es la única forma de
que yo puedo traducir el mundo,
es a través de mi
propia experiencia, ¿no?
Y si nos ponemos
teológicos, de hecho,
la única forma de
trascender es a partir de mí.
Y yo veo que la poesía
es, es algo es que está,
que me encontró a mí, tal vez
algo que es una parte de la
experiencia común que tenemos
como seres humanos, tal vez,
o espirituales, si se quiere,
pero que comparte otra cosa con
lo que señalaba Manuel que puede
traducirse en belleza, o
puede traducirse en algo
transcendental y lo que
hablaba Octavio Paz, ¿no?,
que la diferencia entre
poesía, poema y lo poético,
la poesía la podemos
vivir en el poema,
pero en mi experiencia yo trato
de vivir la poesía pero estoy
también estoy es siempre
en busca de lo poético,
y lo poético lo puedo encontrar
en lo cotidiano y en las otras
artes, ¿no?, y de esa forma
la poesía se convierte en una
resonancia que abarca todas esas
experiencias poéticas que yo
puedo plasmar en el papel.
Sin embargo, puedo también
encontrar la poesía en el cine,
en la música o en el refrán,
incluso en un madrazo,
en una mala palabra en el
momento exacto en la calle,
¿no?
Entonces, eso hace que resuene y
ese momento en que la palabra o
la experiencia queda resonando
en una parte que está más allá
de mí, de hecho, una parte que
está tal vez en un registro
akáshico, después yo llego y --
tengo la experiencia en la que
puedo bajar ese conocimiento,
tal vez, esa resonancia
trascendental y ponerla en otro
medio que sirve de
resonador, además,
para que la experiencia se
transforme y nos sigamos
alimentando como una
forma de esperanza, ¿no?
A pesar de que la poesía puede
ser oscura, triste o alegre,
lo poético puede ser
doloroso, puede ser amargo,
puede ser apocalíptico, pero la
experiencia misma y el hecho de
transcenderla, ponerla a resonar
en otro medio y trasmitirla a
los demás, es lo que hace
que haya esperanza y que la
vida continúe.
Así la veo yo.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Diolinda Ekonomo:
Buenas tardes,
mi nombre es Diolinda Ekonomo,
y he disfrutado muchísimo
este programa, este recital,
me encanta la poesía y quiero
agradecer de todo corazón al
Teatro de la Luna por la
oportunidad que nos da de
reunirnos y gozar de
programas como éste.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Bueno, entonces porque
esto tiene estar en español,
ustedes tendrán que
sufrir, [risas].
Quiero decir que una
novela es como un cuerpo,
y la poesía, es como el alma.
Que una novela es como cerveza;
y la poesía es como
whisky o licor.
[ Risas ]
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Bueno, bien,
como ustedes ven la posibilidad
de que la experiencia poética se
transforme también en una
manera de entender el mundo,
no solamente de manifestarlo
de esta forma,
hace que símiles relacionados
con esas dos formas de escritura
nos escancien y nos
obliguen a reflexionar.
Y por eso voy a terminar
simplemente antes de pasar a una
última ronda, porque no podemos
de pasar de las 3:30 p.m. con
algo que decía nuestro
amigo César Vallejo,
"hay quienes son poetas
porque escriben versos,
y hay quienes escriben
versos porque son poetas".
Vamos terminar ahora con una
última ronda de un poema por
poeta, en el tiempo
que nos queda.
Y después si veo que nos
queda algunos minutos, pues,
buscaré algún otro arreglillo
para utilizar el tiempo de la
mejor poética manera
que podamos.
>> Plinio Chahín: Voy a leer un
poema, digo todos son de amor,
pero este es más
erótico, [risas].
Claro. "Pero tú ahí desnuda con
tu desolación en otros líquidos,
transfigurado el sexo y
los labios sangrantes.
Rabiosa lisonja o vacía
sortija de otras sombras.
Afilas la piel en
ostras que se enseñan,
otrora olor que la tome dijo,
horror, miedo, bestia, dice,
'mordiste en mi dolor,
la mueca, el odio'".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Carlos Velásquez
Torres: Bueno, nunca --
>> Rei Berroa: Te
pillamos desprevenido.
>> Carlos Velásquez
Torres: No, no,
es parte de mi personalidad,
eso -- , [risas].
Esto es completamente
deliberado, [risas].
OK. Este último poema,
¿eh?, bueno,
yo soy colombiano y escribí
este poema que lleva como título
"El país más triste del mundo",
no sé de pronto alguien puede
ponerle el título del país
que quiera.
"El país más triste del mundo.
La ciudad nocturna rumorea y
murgas de abandono recorren
audaces la maraña de calles y
avenidas plagadas de mujeres
deliciosas que comparten sus
caderas al sonoro retozar de los
tambores, y hombres
ebrios cansados,
pero expertos en la rutina de
compartir un lecho de tarde
en tarde.
La juerga vespertina devora con
avidez al silencio, la fiesta,
el jolgorio hacen más oscura la
procesión de almas que sueñan
acaso el sosiego, mudas como
invasoras de tierras ignotas y
hostiles Hubo cantos,
olvidados ya,
pero sé que los hubo que hacían
noble el dolor y hermanaban al
hombre con los pájaros, tiempos
en que la madera viva reverdecía
tranquila al sol de los venados.
Danzas hubo que susurraban
sonoras el galope de las
listadas cebras en sabanas
lejanas y candentes y cueros que
trepidaban en el centro
del bosque y la eternidad.
La sangre de mil colores
recuerda acaso que la sierpe fue
la hermana y el lobo
y el babuino,
mientras la lengua se extravía
y la mudez heredada por el plomo
agota el sueño que
olvidamos antes de la aurora.
El país de las ciudades
repite constante y pertinaz,
las comandas de la prole,
aristocracias de remedo que
alientan la caterva y la alegría
del sábado ha convertido
en máscara festiva la mueca
horrorosa de la muerte que vive
a expensas de nuestra vida.
Es el país más triste del mundo
el que desvanece el llanto en
noches alocadas, tan cobarde
como el olvido de sus muertos".
[Aplausos], muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Manuel Iris: Bueno, yo leí ya
poemas para mi esposa y mi hija,
y uno de mi mamá,
que voy a leer.
[Inaudible], uno último --
no, para otras de las mujeres
importantes en mi vida que es
mi abuela.
Mi abuela es quizá la persona
que más me ha querido en la vida
y de pronto un día --
>> Rei Berroa: Nosotros
también [fonético].
>> Manuel Iris: Todavía
me quiere más mi abuela,
[risas], yo te quiero mucho.
Hasta que un día mi
abuela, le dio Alzheimer,
y empezó a confundirme, empezó
a confundir mi rostro con el
rostro del hombre que la
abandonó con cinco hijos.
Y yo de pronto veía el
rostro de mi abuela,
que es el rostro que me
ha visto con más amor,
preguntándome "¿por
qué me hiciste esto?",
y me tocaba explicarle cada vez
que nos veíamos que yo no era
él, lo cual a mí me
da la certidumbre,
eso es una de mis
obsesiones poéticas,
es que todo es una repetición.
Y en este caso,
esta conversación repetida
me servía para confirmar que
incluso mi rostro no
es mío por primera vez.
El poema se llama "Ecos".
"Mordida por su edad, mi abuela
le habla al anterior que la vio
por mis ojos, '¿No te
dolió jamás dejarme así,
con cinco niños?
¿No nos pensabas nunca?'
Me siento culpable del silencio
que mi rostro, antes de mí,
guardó; pero le aclaro,
'amor, yo soy tu nieto,
el primer hijo de tu hijo menor,
soy el que vive lejos'
Ya decía yo, me dice,
'que no tenía sentido que yo
fuera una vieja y tú siguieras
igual', [risas].
Me abraza con alivio, como si
esa conversación entre nosotros
acabara pero sucederá,
como es costumbre,
la siguiente vez
que nos veamos".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Jorge Galán: Bien, este
poema se llama "Romero".
Yo lo escribí por un hombre
de mi país, Monseñor Romero,
que tuvo una muerte -- bueno,
él es un hombre que se
transformó y en 1980 mientras
daba una misa, en el momento de
bendecir, de la consagración,
de hacer la consagración, pues,
recibe un disparo en el corazón.
Y claro es una muerte,
es tremenda, ¿no?,
y creo que ese momento es
un antes y un después en la
historia de mi país.
Y escribí este poema que
intenta un poco contar cómo fue
ese momento.
"Romero levanta sus brazos
y toca con sus dedos dos
eternidades, el tiempo de mi
niñez y el de mi vejez se unen
cuando los unen sus dedos.
Las monjas cantan y no saben
que es un canto de despedida.
Los pañuelos que cubren sus
cabellos son días de lluvia.
Romero levanta la copia y la
hostia y su voz es el mar,
y su cuerpo, un acantilado
donde se estrella el mar.
Hay brisa y bullicio de
gaviotas en la pequeña nave de
la iglesia.
Los cristales se iluminan con
el fuego que llega desde fuera.
Suena un disparo al mismo tiempo
que todas las campanas del
mundo, que las campanas de
todas las iglesias de la tierra
menos una.
El disparo atraviesa el
aire, veloz como un milagro.
Las voces cesan y el silencio
avanza cien pasos y los gritos
repentinos son una estampida de
toros que se estrella contra un
muro de piedra, lo destruyen
y escapan a los montes.
Monseñor cae y nadie
le escucha caer.
Su túnica es blanca, su túnica
blanca es una playa de verano,
pero la luz ha sido manchada por
los inmensos cuervos que graznan
en el atardecer.
Las monjas son olas que
se juntan en la marisma.
Sostienen su cabeza como si
intentaran sostener el cielo con
sus pequeñas manos, pero no es
suficiente, no es suficiente.
Nada resulta suficiente.
La muerte se acerca
y se inclina,
en la puerta de la iglesia
una sombra se aleja.
Las campanas continúan
su terrible lamento.
En algún lugar bajo el sol los
ciervos se inclinan a beber.
Un hombre se persigna
sin tener un motivo.
Y Romero dice una
última palabra,
inaudible como el sonido de
las pisadas del escorpión en
el desierto.
Su cabeza cae como una fruta.
Un perfume de fuego y de
ceniza desborda la ciudad.
San Salvador se llena
de algo sin saberlo.
La sombra que avanza por las
calles aplasta el perfume,
pero no puede destruirlo.
Las campanas continúan doblando.
Metal sin ruido, un lamento,
un grito que no haya su final y
continúa temblando en el aire de
marzo, desde ese día y
cada día, en todo tiempo".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Pedro Larrea Rubio:
Una pregunta de obsesión,
sino de obsesión, de interés,
creo que universal,
es ¿quién soy yo?
Quizás todos nos hayamos hecho
esta pregunta, hay momentos,
sí [fonético], [risas],
¿verdad?
OK.
>> El vasallo [fonético].
>> Pedro Larrea Rubio:
El vasallo.
Y es una pregunta que en
mí sí ha sido una obsesión.
Cuando intento explicarla
en términos culturales,
pienso que la base de
mi cultura es doble.
Por una parte, yo me crie
entre una familia de ámbito
mediterráneo y otra
familia de ámbito atlántico.
Es un ejemplo de
dualidad, pero sobre todo,
quizás los grandes
contrastes de nosotros mismos,
nos los da el tiempo y
este poema está basado en
esa reflexión.
"Soy más viejo que mi cuerpo,
como el cedro es más viejo
que sus hojas actuales.
Hiberno como el cedro,
y despierto cuando la batuta
de las horas golpea el atril
del espacio.
Por mí han pasado corcheas
como por el cedro macillos
de colibríes.
Soy el que fui con la corteza
de lo que seré sin estrenar.
Soy más joven que mi espíritu.
Mi casa es un cráter que
creó una roca de otro mundo,
antes del invierno nuclear
y de la primera glaciación.
No comprendo que ninguna
pirámide sea más antigua que el
más joven de mis olivos,
ni entiendo la trompeta frigia
y el arpa persa que a veces toco
por intuición.
Me confunde ser testigo del
nacimiento de una galaxia.
Cómo puedo ser viejo cuando soy
joven y joven cuando soy viejo.
Cómo puede no existir una
edad única que me dé sentido,
que justifique mi presencia en
el pasado y el presente y que
imponga paz al bramido
bélico del estar siendo y del
ser estando.
¿Cuándo poseeré un rostro
definitivo para todos
los espejos?
¿Cuándo podré decir este soy
yo sin equivocarme demasiado?
Soy joven pero conozco los
secretos de la cartografía.
Soy viejo pero tengo agilidad
para boxear contra mí mismo.
Soy lo que falta antes de ser y
lo que queda después de estar.
A quién odiaré más que al
palimpsesto de mi carne.
A quién tendré por cómplice
en el soborno de mi espíritu.
A quién daré los labios de
quien me habita sucesivamente
en soledad".
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Sí, sí, que
ese tiempo [inaudible].
>> Milagros Terán: OK.
Perfecto. Bueno, voy a leer
ahora de mi poemario que se
llama "Sol lascivo",
que lo escribí en África y
que ganó un premio nacional en
Nicaragua, el premio
Mariana Sansón.
Se llama "Estampas", son seis.
"Seco el aire del tiempo no hay
sudores gozosos solo la humedad
de estas lágrimas que caen
sobre la tierra fértil africana.
Dos. Fértil el negro
vientre de este continente,
manos entrelazadas son un
corro contra la tristeza.
Tres. La soledad no existe
la echan afuera desde
el nacimiento.
La docena de madres ahuyenta
a la hiena del hambre.
Cuatro. Caminan bajo el sol
con sus túnicas blancas hasta
encontrar la sombra del Masasa,
cierran los ojos invocando a
Papá Dios, suena el tambor,
y el domingo se desenrolla
como culebra sobre granito.
Cinco. Soy un árbol,
dijo la tarde,
cuando el viejo inmóvil en mitad
de la calle vociferaba contra
los vehículos, los
blancos y el tiempo.
Seis. Los ojos volteados
como canicas,
bolas de vidrio oscuras y
el aliento fétido a Chibuku.
Una gran sonrisa muestra
la desdentada boca,
oso hormiguero de la noche
entre latas que escupen fuego
y pesadumbre".
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Y con esto
exactamente a las 3:30 p.m.,
[risas], cerramos
la primera etapa,
este primer momento del 26
Maratón de Poesía del Teatro de
la Luna.
Gracias.
>> Cualquiera diría que
estaba preparado [fonético].
>> Rei Berroa: ¿Eh?
>> Que cualquier diría
que estaba preparado.
>> Rei Berroa: Como si lo
hubiésemos planificado.
Gracias Georgette.
Gracias Talia.
Gracias Catalina,
que estaba por aquí.
Gracias a todos ustedes poetas,
gracias por la palabra y
la experiencia poética de
esta tarde.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov